you know I come down to Palm Springs
because the sun is supposed to shine
every day here it's supposed to be warm
today I think it's like 10 degrees
Celsius and a slight drizzly rain
you can't always expect you know perfect
conditions for anything including
language arts whatever happens you've
got to find ways to enjoy it I can enjoy
my day I'm gonna read a book I'm reading
an interesting book I read a fascinating
book about the Greeks by the way and I'm
going to study some language and we'll
see what else I can do I won't be able
to think off I could but the main thing
in any field of activity is to find ways
to enjoy it so find ways to enjoy your
language learning don't burden yourself
with some kind of sense of obligation
you got to remember this or you got to
be able to produce that or pronounce
this just enjoy it and good things will
happen bye for now